au 64e jour de la guerre en ukraine
après moscou le secrétaire général de
l'onu et en ukraine ce jeudi première
visite d'antonio goûter res dans le pays
depuis le début de l'invasion russe il
s'est rendu tout à l'heure dans la
banlieue de kiev à boro janka il est
actuellement toujours dans la banlieue
de kiev à butch à vous voyez sur sur ces
images la voiture d'antonio goûter res
armelle charrier bonjour
antonio gutiérrez qui doit ensuite se
rendre à haïr pin après borodianka et
butch à des localités théâtre de
massacres imputés à l'armée russe hélas
les ukrainiens espère convaincre antonio
guterres est ce qu'il ya bien eu des
crimes de guerre de la part de la russie
oui alors vous avez raison ce sont des
crimes de guerre et ce à la terminologie
a été reconnue on a même de toute
manière une enquête qui a été ouverte
par la cour pénale internationale qui a
envoyé des enquêteurs sur place donc
elle portera ses fruits mais ce sera le
temps de la justice les forcément
beaucoup plus long et vous vous rappelez
que lorsque antonio guterres s acquitter
les états unis est d'abord allé à moscou
ce qui a inquiété les ukrainiens parce
qu'il se dit d'abord il va chercher la
version de vladimir poutine n'a qu'elle
conteste qu'il y ait eu des massacres
fait par ses troupes dans l'est dans ces
endroits là en disant que c'est une
manipulation ukrainienne alors il ya
certainement eu les explications il a
certainement donné son point de vue est
ce que c'est une simple déclaratif comme
il le fait ou est ce qu il a étayé et
que lorsque on était dans un rapport en
présentiel on n'était pas en visio là on
était vraiment avec deux personnes qui
se parlaient est ce que les russes ont
fourni des éléments ça on ne sait pas ce
qu'il en est c'est que là tout de suite
on a pour les ukrainiens quelque chose
qui est capital à leurs yeux il faut
qu'ils puissent eux aussi montré qu' il
s'agit non seulement de massacres qui
ont été commis par les russes mais en
plus le ils veulent qu'il y ait la
terminologie du génocide qui soit dessus
alors il ya eu beaucoup de visites qui
ont été faites à la presse
internationale et le droit de venir on a
vu là quant au new goûter rey s'était
quand même entouré d'énormément de
caméras qu'il y avait des services de
sécurité important parce que dans ce cas
le niveau de violences est exacerbée
et parce que l'enjeu est capital trouver
d'abord si effectivement ce sont bien
les russes la communauté internationale
dans sa majorité a dit effectivement que
c'était les russes mais ça reste les
américains ça reste les européens
antonio guterres s ils représentent
aussi tous les autres pays qui ne
considère pas cela qui peuvent suivre
effectivement les russes et puis la
terminologie de génocide elle est
capitale la france ne la reprends pas
pour l'instant parce que c'est quelque
chose qui ressemble à la loi il faut
effectivement avoir un moment donné
stigmatiser la population il faut avoir
chassé la population il faut avoir
exterminé la population et avoir fait
tout ça dans un cadre est très
spécifique donc c'est pour cela que
c'est vraiment très important et que
pour le président et line ce qui s'est
vraiment ce moment qui va être il va il
faut qu'il arrive à convaincre antonio
perez antoniuk ou thérèse qui a déclaré
tout à l'heure une guerre au 21ème
siècle est une absurdité
mais finalement l'onu n'a pas pu faire
grand chose il a raison une guerre au
21ème siècle est une absurdité
malheureusement ça nous tétanise tous
parce que depuis une antiquité depuis la
nuit des temps il ya des guerres et à
chaque fois on se dit on va les éviter
et à chaque fois on avance et on se rend
compte que on a des moyens de plus en
plus modernes d'armement et qu'on
n'arrive pas à éviter la guerre
simplement aujourd'hui ce qui doit
discuter c'est comment est ce qu'on
arrive à mettre des corridors
humanitaires
comment est ce qu'on arrive à sauver des
civils comment est ce qu'on arrive à
trouver des solutions pour les réfugiés
le hcr dépend de l'onu c'est au comité
aux réfugiés parce qu'on n'y en a plus
de 5 millions maintenant et encore plus
si on compte ce qui se passe en interne
en ukraine et que ça ça a été
effectivement c'est monté très
rapidement
l'ol lui était prise de court on a
complètement oublié qu'ils avaient du
bilatéralisme on est arrivé sur des
solutions entre les américains entre les
russes entre les européens et là
effectivement lui ce de multilatéralise
parents ce tous les autres pays c'est
arrivé donné effectivement un discours
un peu plus de paix on l'espère et en
même temps quand on regarde l'historique
des guerres chaque fois qu'il dit à ses
yeux braqués sur la diplomatie
internationale sur les plus hauts
sommets de la diplomatie internationale
en règle générale ça fait les tensions
dans les deux camps et souvent ce sont
les victimes qui peuvent encore être
faites chez des civils